this movie is getting slammed by critics
don't worry I'm here Green Lantern oh
yeah Green Lantern's the story of Hal
Jordan played by Ryan Reynolds he's a
daredevil who flies jets and pretty much
has an awesome job and then he gets
inducted into the Green Lantern Corps
which are pretty much like the Jedi they
keep the peace
these guys have magical rings not
lightsabers and when they all use these
rings these are some sweet scenes right
here these rings can make anything they
can imagine so it's really cool to see
them fight with these rings I mean they
kick them they go through a brick wall
they make a brick wall behind the guy
that you lands into you can really get
Marvel vs. Capcom 3 with these rings
that was cool to see now Ryan Reynolds
is Hal Jordan I'll let you know right
away I'm not a Green Lantern fanboy so I
don't know if Ryan Reynolds plays a good
Hal Jordan in concordance with the Green
Lantern lore it was good in the movie
though I mean he was funny he was cool
he was human he was sarcastic he had the
right amount of douchebaggery kind of
remind me of that guy that's cool that's
probably pushing it wasn't it however I
wish the other lanterns did more you see
the other lanterns but they don't do
much else other than hold their rings up
to the sky you know do the whole earth
fire wind water Hart Captain Planet
thing and Blake Lively's in the movie
and yeah she's ridiculously hot she is
so hot it's like stupid she has a long
career ahead of her let me tell you tell
people get bored with her like they did
Megan Fox now we move on to the villains
of the story parallax which is pretty
much a big cloud with a floating head
that devours worlds he's gonna wipe out
the entire galaxy should probably stop
that
that being said he's a big cloud with
tentacles with a floating head and
Hector Hammond dr. big head who has a
big head he's all psychic Peter
Sarsgaard is a really good actor he was
really good in the movie as that part
that being said I didn't care about
Hector Hammond I mean he's a guy who's
envious of Hal Jordan I knew that would
be the kid for some odd reason I saw the
trailer and I was like okay that's going
to be the guy who envies Hal Jordan and
becomes a villain and has a big head you
know what they say about doctors with
big heads they're pointless in movies
the suit looks a lot better though I saw
the trailer like the teaser trailer and
I was like that suit is horrible and
they're not gonna make it any better
because they're not going to but they
did they really did suit has these cool
effects going on some lighting effects
some like energy coming off of it not in
that cheesy shitty like light kind of
way but it's like smokes coming off it
look cool and the movie did have some
pacing issues it was a little slow I
wanted to see more of Oya
the planet that all the Green Lantern's
are on you see it for like 10 minutes in
the movie I'll stretch it to 15 because
I'm nice but all in all it's a small
part of the movie in
you're back on earth and you know he's
just kind of dealing with [ __ ] I enjoyed
seeing him dealing with stuff but I also
enjoyed a lot of the cool Green Lantern
ish things you know when he's using the
ring and throwing down and all that
awesome like materializing things out of
thin air so I wish they kind of blended
the two a little more like all I'm
dealing with things I'm becoming a Green
Lantern because I'm fighting crime
I don't know catch a bank robber doing
more than you know the two things you
did there were a few parts that I lacked
in like I always found it funny that
like those little masks on people's
faces somehow no one recognizes them and
they kind of address that in a way that
I always thought a movie should so that
was cool props to them in the end Green
Lantern's not as good as I wanted it to
be but it's not as bad as I thought it
would be I mean if you go into Green
Lantern and you know it's not going to
be like The Dark Knight or Iron Man or
x-men first class or Thor then you
should be alright it's a total popcorn
flag I won't say it's a good time but it
is a fun time
no alcohol required it's converted 3d so
the 3ds negligible so save yourself a
few bucks watch it in 2d you'll enjoy it
a lot more I mean I'm not going to go
out of my way to see the movie again but
if my friends are all going to a movie
and they're dragging me to Green Lantern
I'd see it again so did you see Green
Lantern are you like a big Green Lantern
fan is Ryan Reynolds good as Hal Jordan
I don't know if he is comment below let
me know and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more